it's difficult for an evolutionary
biologist to understand some of the
arguments against evolution that are in
the public domain I mean the evidence
for evolution is is not only
overwhelming but it drives everything we
do
Goldschmidt famously there's a famous
geneticist once said that nothing in
biology can be understood except in the
light of evolution and that's true I
think we wouldn't understand as much as
we do about the pathways that I
described without the evolutionary side
of it that that makes it all makes it
all real
especially in plants we can we can
rewind the clock of recent evolution by
by remaking a hybrid for example and
then seeing how it evolves in the
laboratory or in the field and compare
that to what we know happened even in
recent history and so evolution is an
experimentally tractable topic I mean
it's it's it's it's it's very real one
of the most famous branches in plant
evolution is the difference between
gymnosperms and angiosperms
and let me explain what they are they're
both seed plants so they have seeds but
angiosperms also have flowers
so whereas gymnosperms have a different
sort of reproductive structure account
so people would be very familiar for
example with cones on pine trees which
are gymnosperms and flowers on you know
their favorite garden plant the
difference between gymnosperms and
angiosperms is very important in
evolution because angiosperms were able
to somehow radiate into thousands and
thousands and thousands of species
whereas gymnosperms are rather narrow in
their in their species also gymnosperms
have very very large genomes that are
largely composed of transposons
transposons are pieces of DNA that can
move around the genome and so they they
can move potentially and cause genetic
as well as epigenetic changes without
having to go through a sexual cross and
most genomes are actually composed
mostly of transposon so for example the
human genome is about 50% transposons
and only about 5% genes
the maze genome is even more extreme
it's about 80% transposons and only 2 or
3% genes so the bulk of the genome is
actually prepared if you like for every
genetic change and this is the area that
we work on the most looking at the the
way in which transposon control and
especially epigenetic transposon control
has influenced the the phenotype the the
the properties of plants over the
generations darwin famously referred to
the radiation of angiosperms that the
generation of thousands of species as an
abominable mystery because it didn't fit
with his gradual change hypothesis of
evolution and we think that maybe some
of the explanation lies in this ability
to to control transposons
but that's that's very speculative but
it's an interesting interesting thought